[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
nous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport
l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département a c'est
parti pour le sommaire au rugby
versailles a remporté ce dimanche le
derby vinoy contre le mlsgp en huitièmes
de finale du championnat de france
honneur
il garde toujours l'espoir d'une montée
en fin de saison plus d'informations
assurant ce magazine handball club de
trappes termina tison premiers du
championnat d'excellence départementale
est invaincu en s'imposant largement
contre les clayes-sous-bois ce samedi
sur le score de 45 à 28 foot projecteurs
dans quelques instants
tennis ce sera une grande première
depuis à michaël llodra florian la
caténaire sur rinderknecht de l'illinois
ont foulé les courts de la porte
d'auteuil pour disputer leur premier
roland garros en double reportage à
suivre
on ouvre maintenant une large page
résultats
[Musique]
on commence donc ce magazine par du
rugby ce dimanche versailles réussi un
coup de maître en venant à bout de
l'entente maisons laffitte saint germain
en laye poissy en huitièmes de finale du
championnat de france honneur le score
13 à 3 dans une ambiance électrique des
images de nicolas landry à montage de
romain respini la célébration était au
niveau de la décharge d'énergie déployée
par le rc versailles ce dimanche les
joueurs de la cité royale se qualifier
en quarts de finale du championnat de
france honneur après une victoire dans
le derby vinoy contre le mls gp ce qu'en
finale a trait à trois gros matches en
savez on a on n'a pas forcément réussi à
produire ce qu'on aurait voulu produire
aujourd'hui on a beaucoup subi et on
allait chercher avec les tripes parce
que c'était vraiment dur quand cette
équipe de maisons laffitte car elle
achète une victoire acquise en grande
partie grâce à une défense resserrée
dans les derniers mètres qui a perturbé
leurs adversaires je vais récupérer des
vidéos donc je savais un peu comme jouer
donc on avait mis en place un système de
défense qu'à fonctionner avec des avec
des couloirs une défense de fer qu'il
faudra revoir au prochain tour les
versets y affronteront chalon sur saône
une des meilleures équipes de division
honneur est candidat au titre
versailles devrait aller battre pour
continuer à rêver de la montée lorsqu'on
ce qu'on vaut face à une grosse équipe à
sans pression aucune
voilà pour le coup on a rarement par la
pression donc avoir convoqué face à des
semi-pros vallières on sait que c'est
très compliqué on verra en fonction des
résultats il ya des tapis verts etc
on peut pas vraiment calculé sur les
phases finales après on prend les
matches les uns après les autres on aura
un gros match dans deux semaines on sait
qu'il ya un énorme et voir ce qui va
nous attendre à fait
on n'est pas morts on est encore là et
tant qu'on est là il va falloir bien on
tapait la rencontre sera programmée le
dimanche 10 juin sur terrain neutre
entre la bourgogne et l'yonne les
supporters versailles et le rêve déjà
d'un nouvel exploit de leurs protégés
après le rugby on continue par du
football et le championnat de régionale
à 4 lors de la dernière journée trappe à
enchaîner une deuxième victoire
consécutive sur le score de 3 à 0
sa victime du jour le club du csm
puteaux cette neuvième victoire de la
saison enregistré ce dimanche permet aux
trappistes de remonter au classement
longtemps dans les profondeurs de cette
régionale cats il termine neuvième sur
quatorze équipes engagées de bonne
augure pour la saison prochaine dans le
championnat de première division de
district ont joué également le dernier
match de la saison ce dimanche parmi les
principaux résultats guyancourt termine
par une victoire 3 1 sur le terrain du
chesnay et conclu à sa saison par une
belle troisième place
maurepas s'impose 4 à 0 sur le terrain
des pôles et conserve sa place dans le
top 5 de la division enfin à montigny le
bretonneux s'incline 3-2 sur le terrain
du leader les mureaux et restera dans sa
division à l'année à prochaine en
football américain terrible désillusion
pour les templiers d'elancourt en
demi-finale de play-off de 2e division
en course pour la montée à l'échelon
supérieur les élans courtois ont vu leur
rêve brisé ce week-end se sont inclinés
44 à 40 à l'extérieur d'un match à
rebondissements sur le terrain des
corsaires des vrais une équipe pourtant
invaincu cette année
la saison se termine donc prématurément
pour les templiers qui devront retenter
leur chance l'année à prochaine enfin
basket on joue également
ce week-end ce dimanche à
croissy-sur-seine et senior féminine du
paris désirent un basket club ont
largement battu saint germain en laye en
finale de la coupe des yvelines le score
71 à 57 une belle revanche pour la
section qui avait perdu deux finales sur
les deux dernières saisons dans cette
compétition en ball-trap a réussi à
réaliser une saison parfaite dans le
championnat d'excellence départementale
les trappistes sont imposés ce samedi
dans leur gymnase contre l'équipe des
clayes-sous-bois 45 à 28 des images de
nicolas landry un montage de romain à
respini
[Musique]
les invincibles de trappes ont encore
frappé ce samedi 26 mai les trappistes
termina saison premiers du championnat
et invaincu en emportant un ultime match
en excellence départementale contre les
quais sous bois sur un nouveau festival
offensif le score 45 à 28
on avait à coeur de finir en beauté
voilà par match est serré à la fin et
de rester invaincu jusqu'à la fin de la
saison on lave a annoncé on avait envie
de le faire on l'a fait voilà on a fini
le travail
c'est impressionnant c'est un message
fort qu'on en voit notamment aussi après
bon ben c'est un aboutissement aussi
c'est un gros un gros gros travail là on
a très très beau beaucoup beaucoup
travaillé cette saison
l'année prochaine les joueurs évolueront
en division pré régionale 4 ans
seulement après la renaissance du club
un niveau qui ne serait pas l'équipe qui
on arrive dans les deux premières places
eh ben on comptera en région donc c'est
l'objectif clairement de se garder le
groupe de renforcer avec un ou deux
membres et puis
mais puis d'aller chercher la région
sera parti je pense à des équipes qui
ont la prétention de monter l'année
prochaine on sera pas seul et voilà on
sait que ce sera difficile
on peut pas faire du sport en dix ans
joue à moitié on en a encore voilà une
équipe qui se renforçaient l'année
prochaine et voilà on a envie de
continuer l'aventuré
l'objectif c'est de jouer en région
d'abyei club d'origine la saison
reprendra en septembre prochain à
l'occasion d'étendre encore un peu plus
cette série d'invincibilité historique
du club
[Applaudissements]
les trappistes ne sont pas les seuls à
avoir terminé la saison invaincus pour
sa première année de création et les
féminines de ville pourront également
réaliser un sans faute dans le
championnat d'excellence départementale
les joueuses ont remporté 17 victoires
sur la saison en 17 matches disputés
équipes terminent également meilleure
attaque et meilleure défense des
résultats qui permettent au club de
monter dans la division supérieure
on écoute la réaction de la présidente
et joueuses cindy rodrigues ci a
fonctionné je pense l'état d'esprit des
filles avec la création de cette équipe
là envie de montrer que ce soit parce
qu'on se crée que on n'allait pas
être présente et du coup vraiment
beaucoup de motivation de la part des
filles et et ça c'était top
c'était le projet
le projet
dès la première année effectivement
quand on a commencé à entamer nos
matches on s'est vite rendu compte qu'il
y avait qui avait possibilité pour nous
de faire quelque chose cette saison des
débuts d'incendié on joue la montée si
vous voulez rejoindre l'équipe la
section recrute pour la saison prochaine
nous allons maintenant ouvrir une page
gymnastique dans ce magazine début mai
le club de la gemme elancourt maurepas
raflé deux médailles d'or en individuel
aux championnats de france organisés à
auxerre anaïs ghouila guila guillois
pardon les élit le riche et sont
devenues championnes de france nationale
nous avons la chance de les recevoir
toutes les deux en plateau ainsi que la
vice-présidente de la gemme locaux repas
à morgane goulard bonsoir
alors qu'est-ce qui a fait la différence
sur ces championnats de france morgan
d'un plein de choses je pense elles ont
toutes les deux sujets la pression ce
qui est pas facile en compétition
surtout une compétition nationale est
long
comme on dit elle on fait le taf elles
ont fait ce qu'elles savent faire à
l'entraînement et elles ont réussi à
bien me montrer face aux juges et à
faire une belle compétition pour toutes
les deux la pression justement comment
la gère anaïs ça a été dur parce que moi
j'ai commencé la compétition directement
aux barres asymétriques qui j'ai
directement fait une chute
du coup ça peut déstabiliser mais j'ai
su reprendre enfin reprendre et comment
confiance aller pour se remettre dedans
du coup dans la compétition quand ça va
pas dès le début ben on oublie la grée
qui conte à fait juste précédent
précédemment et après on se concentre
sur la grée suivant vous est ce que toi
tu as une technique pour gérer le stress
en compétition non ça s'est plutôt bien
passé
oui mais j'ai pas forcément technique je
me concentre avant de passer sur l'agrès
morgan est ce que vous gérez un petit
peu les gymnastes avant le passage en
compétition est ce que vous leur
apprenez des techniques peut-être pour
se calmer
alors on essaye de leur ordonner des
conseils pour gérer la pression ça soit
ces jeunes ont quand même exactement 12
éliminé en 2005 à nice en 2002 donc
elles sont encore jeunes elles ont pas
encore l'expérience que nos grandes du
club mais on essaie de leur donner des
conseils
et depuis cette année on a essayé de
mettre en place aussi avec une
sophrologue des moments avant les
championnats de france où elles peuvent
apprendre à gérer un peu mieux pour le
stress la pression
comment se concentraient en compétition
comme on ne rien lâcher même si on
revient deux fois rien à gré voilà des
choses et ça fonctionne mieux a priori
alaïs est-ce que vous avez un bon est ce
que tu es un bon souvenir de cette
compétition le meilleur souvenir que
j'ai eue c'était au palmarès quand ils
nous ont rappelé enfin quand ils m'ont
appelé je m'y attendais pas et en fait
j'ai avant la les championnats de france
on avait dit que j'aurais pu faire un
podium mais quand j'ai entendu le
non de la troisième je me suis dit que
c'était que c'était mort entre
guillemets que je serai pas sur le
podium
et ensuite quand ils ont dit région
parisienne et l'encours maurepas bas
j'étais vraiment zélie un souvenir de
cette compétition est la même chose le
moment ils m'ont appelé parce que mon
fils y aller tu aller sur le podium
oui et qu'est ce qu'on ressent justement
quand on arrive sur le podium qu'on
représente ou club parce qu'on sent ben
on est fiers moi j'ai pas carré mais je
pense qu'après l'été étaient fiers de
leur performance qu'elle veut qu'elles
ont réussi c'est un aboutissement elles
ont travaillé toute l'année pour savoir
plusieurs années avant donc je pense
qu'elles étaient fiers de leurs
résultats
vous attendiez ce qui est d aussi bons
résultats ces championnats de france
n'ont pas forcément sur le papier on
part toujours avec des des espoirs on se
dit bon bah voilà
sur le papier elle peut faire un elle
peut faire déjà pu faire 3 le faire on a
des espoirs et des des décos mondiale on
pense qu'il peut se passer des choses
mais après le match et le match et tout
peut arriver pendant une compétition
sa peugeot chute ça peut jouer avec le
stress ça peut jouer à la condition
physique la fatigue tout peut arriver
et à ce niveau là c'est vrai comme on le
moindre dixième comte donc donc rien
n'est joué jusqu'à ce que le dernier à
gré soit passé anaïs une médaille comme
celle-là c'est combien d'années de
travail
je répète c'est bien moi ça fait 7 8 ans
que je fais de la gym et ça fait deux
ans que je suis à elancourt maurepas et
en revenant dans ce club j'ai quand même
fait une progression énorme
du coup ils m'ont appris beaucoup de
choses et je pense que ça a joué aussi
quand même comment expliquez vous que
le jem et l'encours maurepas soit le
meilleur club des yvelines
en gymnastique comment l'expliquez vous
c'est parce qu'on est les meilleurs mais
en tout cas c'est vrai que on essaye de
donner le maximum aux entraîneurs
essayer de toujours performé avec les
gymnastes menacé de mettre des choses en
place pour améliorer les conditions
d'entraînement une section sportive par
exemple pour que les filles puissent
entraîner moins dans le soir que
puissent combiner l'école et la
gymnastique
on essaye comme je voulais dit de mettre
des choses en place pour gérer la
pression
voilà avec des petites choses on essaye
d'améliorer les conditions
d'entraînement
je pense que nos entraîneurs aussi sont
performants il faut le dire sont les
meilleurs du des très content de les
avoir
je ne sais pas en tout cas on est très
content de les avoir et ils sont très
performants donc après voilà je pense
que des résultats aussi peut-être à
mettre le monde et quand on voit qu'on a
des résultats en tête des nouvelles
gymnastes s'inscrire chez nous et le
monde a mal de monde les prochaines
échéances pour le club de gym à
elancourt maurepas c'est le week-end
prochain à villefranche sur saône et
donc nous avons trois équipes en
compétition à finalité nationale la dn1
qui doit se maintenir en division
nationale 1 c'est l'objectif principal
et puis deux autres équipes
la division nationale 3 et nationale b
merci à toutes et 3 déplacer sur ce
plateau vous souhaite de remporter un
maximum de métal de médailles est déjà
sur le week-end prochain
merci beaucoup on continue ce magazine
par du tennis le prestigieux tournoi de
roland garros a débuté ce dimanche du
côté de la porte d'auteuil les
spectateurs pourront notamment voir
rafael nadal ou encore novak djokovic
mais également deux illinois arthur
rinderknecht et florian la cad de
joueurs qui ont tapé leurs premières
balles dans le département des images de
manon varaldo avantages du rodger
federer de la rédaction romain respini
l'ambiance est détendue pourtant dans
quelques heures florian la cat et arthur
rinderknecht joueront sur les courts de
roland garros c2i vinoy de 22 ans
bénéficié d'une invitation pour jouer
sur ce tournoi du grand chelem en double
et première pour un joueur du
département depuis un certain michael
llodra
on est très chanceux d'avoir vu cette
fois le quart avant doublé et je suis
vraiment impatient de vivre pleinement
cette expérience de mon premier roland
garros c'est génial c'est top quartier
auront forcément on s'y attendait pas
forcément mais mais c'est vraiment un
super cadeau on va essayer de se
concentrer à 100% pour pour en tirer le
meilleur
les deux tennismen qui dépasse les 1
mètre 95 ne sont pas venus pour faire de
la figuration porte d'auteuil
les deux droitiers ont déjà travaillé
sur leurs points forts et leurs points
faibles ou préparer ce rendez vous je
dirais concerts tous les deux très bien
donc devrait être plutôt assez solide au
service mais c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas
forcément les meilleurs retourneurs de
du monde donc pressés de tenir leurs
services et de briques et une deux fois
de temps en temps pour regagner quelques
matchs je pense qu'on est assez complet
on se connaît depuis qu'on est plus
petit on a joué ensemble pas mal de fois
donc je pense que notre force ça va être
la cohésion d'équipé à la bonne entente
premier match pour ce duo yves binois ce
mardi 29 milles contre la terre australe
où georges est né john millman nicolau
ce basij billy la rencontre est à suivre
à partir de 11h du côté de la porte
d'auteuil
on prend maintenant la direction du golf
de la vaucouleurs mardi dernier le
tiebreak roland garros fêter sa 27e
édition le département des yvelines
comme tous les ans programme des parties
de golf entre célébrités comme bruno
solo philippe candeloro des ateliers
pour les jeunes du département une
soirée caritative avec de nombreux lots
sportif mise aux enchères comme des
maillots du paris saint germain ou du fc
nantes l'ensemble des profits a été
reversée à l'association sos gaz l on
écoute les réactions au micro de tv 78
sincèrement tous les feux étaient au
vert et puis surtout tout le monde est
souriant tout le monde s'adapte on est
dans une une journée caritative donc on
n'est pas dans la perfection mais on est
dans le dans la solidarité chacun porte
sa petite pierre à l'édifice et au bout
du compte c'est une très belle fête
je suis ravi on peut transmettre mois
plus d'autres intervenants box des
valeurs de camaraderie du collectif je
crois que ça c'est très important pour
les jeunes parce que souvent les jeunes
ont du mal à se retrouver et on est là
pour leur inculquer sûr on peut si on
peut dire en après midi
des valeurs que nos parents nous ont
inculqué l'événement a permis de
récolter 25 1700 euros grâce à cette
soirée des milliers d'enfants vont
pouvoir accéder à l'éducation par le
sport et la santé oms continue à parler
de golf et de la ryder cup vous en avez
désormais l'habitude tous les lundis itv
78 2 vous propose de découvrir les
moments qui ont marqué l'histoire de la
compétition aujourd'hui le président de
la fédération française de golf jacques
charon nous présente l'un de ses plus
beaux souvenirs de la compétition
regarder
[Musique]
je me souviens de la ryder cup 2016 est
il seul tine
nous sommes le dernier jour des parties
d'entraînement le jeudi au trou numéro 7
sur le green il y a
rory mcilroy justin rose henrik stenson
partie d'entraînement sont sur le green
hill pote le pt a c'est long deux mètres
environ dirais-je et le premier rate le
trou et dans parmi les spectateurs une
voix s'élèvent et dit ce n'est pas la
ligne le deuxième patch est oubliée lors
de 2ème joueur portait la même voie
crios ips que le trou était raté ce
n'est pas la ligne le troisième poteau
rate à nouveau et la même voie dit ce
n'est pas la ligne - je l'aurais rentrée
et stetson agacé par cette voie qui les
ridiculise un petit peu en tous les cas
les chambres font l'afutt retrouve le
joueur la personne qui a hurlé comme ça
l'amène sur le green pose la balle 8 ans
potter et à ce moment là justin rose
arrive en courant sort un billet de 100
dollars prend until le plante devant la
balle dont l'enjeu du pote qui sera
jouée 700 dollars
[Applaudissements]
et le spectateur ce mail address pets et
rots la bad
donc vous imaginez la foule en délire
les embrassades les joueurs qui ont
signé le billet de 100 dollars et ce
gars qui est sans doute devenu le
golfeur le plus heureux du monde
[Musique]
on poursuit ce magazine par une aventure
de viser minois seront tentés de partir
en finlande pour participer au raid
symbiose du 24 au 29 janvier 2019 un
rendez-vous qui mêle défi à sportif et
opération caritative pour nous parler de
ce rendez-vous nous recevons sur ce
plateau les 2 illinoise qu'avant le
kermorvan de voisins-le-bretonneux et
delphine huet de mareil leguillon
bonsoir alors pourquoi avez vous décidé
de participer à cette aventure
alors déjà c'est pour leur aide finlande
trophy et passe un bios symbiose c'est
notre team
c'est le nom de notre it bag en dessous
wagon débat lui-même et donc
bah moi c'est quelque chose qui est déjà
mûrement réfléchie depuis beaucoup
d'années parce que je suis commerçante
et j'ai eu à faire en fait avait a
beaucoup de clients en fait qui ont
malheureusement le cancer certains qui
sont sortis pas d'autres
et c'est vrai que voilà c'est tombé
comme ça mais j'adore les enfants
donc j'en ai 3 et c'est pour ça que je
veux partir pour courir pour récolter un
maximum d'argent pour donner aux
associations pour essayer de donner un
petit peu de bonheur aux enfants en fait
qui ont le cancer malheureusement dans
les hôpitaux et pour une autre
association aussi qui est très
importante c'est pour les femmes qui ont
eu le cancer du sein
là c'est pour la reconstitution ma mère
donc c'est vraiment très très
particulier donc
donc voilà pour pouvoir les aider en
fait à organiser des réunions à pouvoir
expliquer aux femmes qu'elles ne sont
pas toutes seules et donc voilà que je
parle beaucoup parlé un petit peu
delphine delphine alors pourquoi vous
participez à la compétition on peut dire
ça
on était sur un peu la même chose après
les c'est vrai que l'idée est venue de
carole au début et à côté car était
également un côté compétition ouais
après c'est vrai qu'une aventurière dans
là où tout fait moi ya quinze mille
raisons pour lesquelles je voulais faire
ce raid est quand qu un rouble a proposé
c'était vraiment tous et je pense qu on
a 40 ans toutes les deux enfin plus de
40 ans les enfants sont faits la maison
et fait le mari là aussi et on a enfin
moi ça arrive au bon moment où on avait
vraiment envie de
une envie de dépassement de soi
peut-être ça est en fait un peu tout
mélanger fédérer autour de soi donner
aux autres venir en aide à des
associations alors on est plein
d'énergie toutes les deux je pense qu'on
a un mental une détermination et le fait
de donner à désosser associe à des
associations pardon pardon de se lever
le matin et de se dire courir c'est bien
mais pouvoir pour les autres en gros
voilà c'est mieux et voilà reprendre le
sport enfin moi je vois là c'est super
carole est ce que vous vous entraînez de
façon intense pour son rendez vous vous
risquez d'aller dans la neige sous des
températures qui rouleront les moins 35
degrés alors moi par chance quand même
je travaille au froid depuis pas mal
d'années puisque
je travaille dans une boucherie donc le
français voilà c'est quand même un peu
mon mallette motive non-stop
mais malgré tout ouïe jeu en fait j'ai
repris la course
et quand même le sport parce que moi
j'adore les challenge donc pour
quelqu'un qui n'a jamais vraiment couru
en fait ça fait douze fois que je cours
je suis assez ce km déjà
donc je pense que c'est déjà voilà et
puis de toute façon je suis très motivé
et vous entraîner toutes les deux
ensemble
on essaye d'une fois par semaine mais
c'est vrai que les agendas de l'une et
l'autre sont un peu compliqué donc on va
on est on essaye de se caler ont une
fois par semaine moi pour le petit clin
d'oeil là il ya 1 2 il ya eu de reporter
find a way reportage sur les jeux m
bon moi j'ai versé ma petite larme déjà
derrière ce que je faisais partie de ce
club là est un jeune et on était déjà un
très bon club et oui on essaye de
s'entraîner ouais hier on a participé au
ces le trial dessert je crois à la
queue-lez-yvelines juin ouais c'est ça
et ba 25 km voilà ça c'est fait et on
arrive bien classés donc ça serait bien
dernière question vous allez affronter
50 équipes et c'est quand même une envie
d'aller le plus haut possible finalement
dans ce classement alors le premier truc
c'est de le finir de la rivière jusqu'au
de jambon mobile rien lâcher après on
s'entraîne mais comme des acharnés
parce que si on arrive dans les cinq
premières on rapporte encore plus aux
associations en fait donc voilà si on
pouvait arriver au podium ce serait
magique j'ai obligé de vous couper le
temps imparti vous avez terminé merci à
tous les deux en tout cas d'être passé
sur ce plateau on suivra avec attention
votre parcours dans le grand nord aussi
rapidement si vous avez 10 secondes
voilà on cherche un partenaire en fait
un club de sport qui veut bien nous
parrainé pour pouvoir justement avoir un
entraînement encore plus poussé que
n'avoir que la course
donc voila c était le petit mot que je
voulais demander le message est passé
merci à vous deux rendez vous à noter
maintenant dans vos agendas le comité
des mines de tennis de table organise le
bal à baldor des yvelines ce samedi et
dimanche au gymnase des droits de
l'homme à guyancourt
au programme des tables aux jeunes le
cellier des tableaux adultes dont de
handisport le dimanche si vous voulez
assister à cette compétition qui réunira
plus de 400 joueurs l'entrée est libre
autre rendez vous à noter dans votre
agenda si vous êtes fan de football ce
sera le match à ne pas manquer ce
week-end dans les yvelines au repas
affronte ce dimanche lui en cours en
finale de la coupe des yvelines le match
s'annonce équilibré les deux équipes
évoluent en 1re division de district en
demi-finale du en course étaient
qualifiés aux tirs au but contre plaisir
et guyancourt s'étaient imposés 5-1
contre avricourt en ferme ce magazine
par deux événements solides qui ont
marqué l'actualité sportive du
département ce week-end tout d'abord à
coignières la ville organisé la
troisième édition de ses foulées
couleurs au total 200 participants ont
réalisé une boucle de 2 km dans la ville
en courant ou en marchant sous une pluie
de maïs coloré un rendez vous festif qui
a plu aux habitants il était au micro de
nicolas temps des séries golo sa grâce à
ça amuse les enfants s'amusent tout le
monde en plus de nature fait bien les
choses sa forme de coeur et la
transpiration
voilà épaté mais ont su ensemble on
transpire en famille c'est important on
est tous en famille ou plus ou moins et
ça nous fait du bien il fait beau on
voit la vie non pas en rose mais toutes
les couleurs ça fait un peu sortir ça
vous fait balader rencontrer des gens se
faire des amis et avoir plein de
couleurs sur soi et s'amuser
dans un autre registre cette fois ci à
plus spartiate plus de 20000 aventuriers
ont participé au mode dès 2018 une
épreuve extrême organisées dans les
mines depuis 2013 à ben les participants
ont dû affronter 20 obstacles sur 13 km
au programme un univers peu hospitalier
avec des bains de boue de l'eau glacée
et des barbelés électrifiés une ambiance
camps militaires cubains reviendra
l'année prochaine dans les yvelines
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine d'ici
là passez une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]